as tu sais que ce soir tu sais que ce
soir il ya un lieu unique l'air avec
richard berry quoi se croyait avec
julien clerc julien clerc maintenant
avec son ex-mari à bonne chance c'est
bien c'est bien formés garde marie
deschamps ben non c'est pour ça que
c'était pas j'ai pas bien bon ça va
il aime les chevaux ça c'est bien cela
c'est un très bon acteur formidable
c'est un bel homme à qu'est ce qui est à
d'autres on n'a pas de section sexuelle
ou formidable the sun a passé des
moments formidables pendant les deux
corps et puis voilà c'est la vie même si
elle s'est donné qu'une impression tant
mieux pour elle attend même ennui
j'espère que ça va être un sujet de
conversation mais tu t'étais marié
bouddhiste avec lui tu te souviens tu
sur la plage où j'étais ago annoncé au
tarif de l'île maurice à l'île maurice
avec les fleurs sur la place beaucoup
les choses qui sont belles qui sont en
raison mais c'est un très bon souvenir
je suis sûr
oui c'est chargeons par mois à chaque
fois qu'il ya dans tout le monde en
parle j'en parle mais qu'est ce qu'il te
dit là bas c'était des moments oui ou
non il n'a pas dit du mal de toi
j'essaie et moi j'essaye j'aime pas
quand même qu'est ce que vous foutez
jean manson à pourquoi justement il
était à chaque fois il dit ça il mais
voilà même été pris en faisait un gros
qu'auparavant ils racontent un peu des
fois comment ça se passait ah oui
comment et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou